Baptiste Mulliez je le disais en
présentant ce sommaire vous êtes un
ancien alcoolo-dépendant c'est même un
terme que j'ai repris auprès de vous
vous validez vous êtes d'accord je suis
complètement d'accord vous avez bu à
partir de 14 ans jusqu'à l'âge de 24 ans
vous êtes sombre désormais depuis 8
années et vous raconter votre histoire
dans ce livre qu'on va voir à l'écran
d'avoir trop trinqué ma vie s'est
arrêtée un livre coécrit avec Judith
lossement losman losman voilà c'est un
témoignage poignant vous racontez tout
sans vous épargner
je voulais savoir pour démarrer cette
émission quand vous commencez à boire à
l'âge de de 14 ans comment ça démarre ce
premier vers quel est l'occasion le
contexte
le contexte c'est j'ai l'impression
d'avoir commencé à boire comme tout le
monde c'est-à-dire mes cellules
n'étaient pas celle de tout le monde
c'est surtout ça à dire en fait j'étais
dans la rue avec des amis avant une
soirée et j'étais super angoissée de
c'était lors de mes premières soirées et
l'angoisse était là est-ce qu'il va y
avoir du monde est-ce que il va falloir
danser est-ce qu'il va falloir approcher
des filles je sais pas danser je sais
pas faire ces choses là et mon pote me
tend une bouteille de rosé et
j'accepte quel est le quels sont les
effets qu'est-ce que vous ressentez à
avec ses premières gouttes d'alcool
c'est une sensation assez sublime que
j'ai adoré et dès le début ça accroche
en fait ça match tout de suite il y a eu
un magnétisme qui était là ou des atomes
crochus j'ai adoré pas le goût le goût
je m'en foutais ce sont les effets et
les effets c'est les effets ils sont
propres à chacun moi je recherchais
surtout
des émotions enfantines oubliées c'est à
dire l'exubérance la liberté fuir la
pression familiale et scolaire je
voulais me sentir libre et l'alcool m'a
permis de noyer tout ça d'anesthésier
tout ça
et petit à petit on tombe dans la
dépendance parce qu'on boit pour les
mauvaises raisons
vous parlez de liberté d'enfants à
retrouver
l'adolescent que vous étiez à l'époque
avait perdu le petit bâtisse qui était
tout joyeux tout gay et vous traversiez
une crise d'adolescence vous diriez à
l'époque ou pas spécialement sûrement
mais après il y a eu un déracinement
parce que j'ai grandi à Londres et mes
parents ont jugé bon de me mettre dans
le système français et ce changement a
été vécu de façon un énorme choc perte
de repères total il y avait une grande
grande pression scolaire qui était là
que je ne voulais pas ressentir vous
étiez un collégien du 16e arrondissement
dans un établissement prestigieux c'est
ça du 16ème arrondissement et vous
viviez donc cette pression de façon très
forte je crois que vous aviez aussi un
amour très profond pour le foot avec
j'adorais le foot et en arrivant en
France moins de foot moins de je
n'arrivais pas à exprimer qui j'étais
comme dans une prison et l'alcool bon
j'ai pas du tout été briefé sur les
risques et les dangers j'ai trouvé était
là une solution miracle une pilule
magique pour pour lâcher pour pour
planer pour retourner dans un monde
enfantin et ça a été bon au début au
début seulement ça vous libère donc de
vous angoisses vous écrivez dans votre
livre c'est assez très intéressant
j'avais un potentiel d'alcoolique on est
alcoolique et il est juste de dire que
tout le monde n'est pas égal face à
l'alcool on n'est pas tous égaux c'est
vrai et je l'ai découvert ça m'a
longtemps frustré parce que je me disais
mais pourquoi moi j'ai un problème alors
que d'autres peuvent boire la même
quantité
après je me mentais à moi-même je buvais
plus et je buvais plus régulièrement
mais j'ai été en colère
d'accepter que j'étais malade alcoolique
parce que
je voulais pas l'accepter je voulais pas
accepter que pourquoi moi mais vous le
réalisez assez vite ça vous avez un
problème avec l'alcool vous vous voyez
la face je me vois donc
16 ans
c'est juste festif j'ai l'impression que
c'est que le week-end mais si on se
penche sur le côté dépendance qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire c'est peut-être aussi
une histoire de contexte et moi dès ma
première gorgée lors d'une soirée je ne
sais plus passer un week-end non
alcoolisé et donc c'est systématique
c'est ça c'est systématique j'ai
l'impression qu'un bon week-end c'est un
week-end alcoolisé sinon c'est un
week-end raté un week-end raté j'ai
l'impression de m'ennuyer de de pas de
pas avoir profité
j'associe l'alcool à tout ce côté festif
convivialité les potes les soirées etc
et ensuite on tombe dans dans la
dépendance parce que je deviens
indépendant de plus en plus de contextes
et à partir de quand à partir de quel
âge ça devient de plus en plus
systématique et un peu plus fort cette
addiction je dirais à partir de mes
études 18 19 quand vous êtes majeur
Majeur et ensuite après la mort de mon
papa ça a été l'ouverture des Vans alors
il faut dire que effectivement vous
allez traverser des tragédies notamment
deux la première entre guillemets c'est
celle de la perte de votre papa quand
vous avez 19 ans une mort tout à fait
brutale et puis vous perdez aussi une
amie qui chute d'une balustrade et qui
s'écrase au sol et décède ça se passe
dans votre salon ça se passe au pied de
votre immeuble c'est deux tragédies sont
effectivement des
de ce que je comprends de votre
témoignage et de votre histoire des
accélérateurs en fait vers l'alcool
aussi c'est des accélérateurs parce que
j'utilise l'alcool comme un anesthésiant
et ça calme le chagrin la douleur alors
j'ai l'impression que ça va me faire
aller mieux effectivement pendant les 10
15 premières minutes il y a un effet
anxiolytique qui est délicieux et j'ai
eu beaucoup beaucoup de mal à me séparer
de ça mais c'était oublier l'effet
dépresseur de l'alcool et tout tous les
lendemains avec les difficultés du
lendemain des difficultés du lendemain
et puis surtout l'exclusion que je
pouvais avoir avec les enfin je ne me
connectais plus aux autres c'était que
de la défonce c'était que de
l'anesthésie donc là c'est plus le
Baptiste qui fait la fête et qui fait de
l'alcoolisme mondain on va dire c'est ça
ça ressemble à quoi au moment de la
tristesse je suis un pantin alcoolisé je
réponds qu'aux désir de l'alcool mon
emploi du temps est juste focus sur
quand est-ce que je vais pouvoir prendre
ma prochaine dose c'est assez incroyable
mais la lumière le néon d'une supérette
va me donner envie de boire
j'organise mon emploi du temps tout le
temps partir avant pour pouvoir avoir ma
dose et avoir de l'avance
cacher de l'alcool boire après
je m'organise tout simplement pour pour
manesthésier ça veut dire que vous avez
vous êtes chez votre petit ami vous avez
un rendez-vous avec une amie un ami vous
organisez tout votre votre journée pour
avoir des cachettes par exemple d'alcool
ou de passer dans le frigo prendre une
lampe et de vodka c'est ce que ça
traduit exactement comme ça
ou je mens je dis que je suis allé et je
suis je dis que je suis chez moi mais en
fait je suis à l'extérieur en train de
picoler je suis tout seul dans des parcs
en train de pleurer ma bouteille à la
main
l'alcool je considérais être ma
meilleure copine mais cette copine elle
m'a détruit ça a vraiment été un amour à
sens unique parce que je l'ai adoré la
bouteille mais elle m'a menti l'alcool
m'a menti moi quand je commence l'alcool
à 14-15 ans alcool me promet d'être
heureux en fait je termine dépressif
l'alcool me promet des amis de
l'intensité je suis juste éteint et je
suis tout seul qu'est-ce que j'ai
souffert de la solitude dans l'alcool
c'est c'est mortifère ça détruit tout
autant que l'addiction en elle-même et
surtout l'alcool m'a promis d'être libre
de planer dans un monde de bisounours
tout rose etc en fait j'ai été un
esclave et ça a été hyper hyper dur de
de m'en séparer et aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que il y a qu'après 8 ans
d'abstinence je redécouvre la vie et
j'apprécie la vie pour qu'elle pour ce
qu'elle est dans son authenticité on va
venir à cette deuxième partie de vie je
voulais terminer sur l'alcool vous avez
mis dans des situations de danger très
très grave jusqu'à une agression
sexuelle que vous racontez dans votre
livre votre entourage à ce moment là
comment les amis votre maman que dont
vous êtes très très proche vos frères
vous êtes une fratrie de 5 garçons
comment ça réagit autour de vous est-ce
qu'on est-ce qu'on se voit la face ou
est-ce qu'on vous dit des choses comment
ça se passe il y a plusieurs choses mais
c'est vrai que d'abord il y a un déni de
la part de l'entourage ma maman m'a
beaucoup excusé ce qui n'est j'ai appris
plus tard pas forcément une attitude à
avoir de continuer à être dans la dans
la maternité de maternité etc elle
m'excuser en pensant que soit j'essayais
de gérer le décès de papa comme je
pouvais soit je faisais une crise d'ado
prolongée soit il y avait de la
dépression mais en fait le problème
était bien plus profond que ça j'étais
dépendant de l'alcool et l'alcool c'est
l'alcool qui nourrissait la dépression
après je m'excluais aussi de tous ces
reproches que je vivais comme
désagressions aussi parce que les avis
moralisateurs les phénomènes de posture
d'autorité je supportais pas ça et on
pouvait pas entrer en dialogue avec moi
si si on avait cette posture là donc ça
m'a poussé à m'exclure et à favoriser
l'isolement volontaire parce que oui il
y a de l'isolement involontaire ou en
fait je suis plus invité parce que je
fous la honte mais il est volontaire
parce que je ne je ne sais pas gérer ce
monde extérieur qui est qui n'est que
agression pour moi alors il y a une
phrase magique de votre maman par jour
qui vous dit est-ce que tu as pensé aux
alcooliques anonymes et là c'est le
début du commencement de la rédemption
et la rémission c'est ça c'est ça alors
ça paraît peut-être simple dit comme ça
il y a eu beaucoup de déclics il y a eu
beaucoup de prise de conscience à ami
longtemps mais c'est vrai que je retiens
cette fameuse phrase de maman qui vient
dans ma chambre et qui me parle des
Alcooliques Anonymes je saurais pas vous
expliquer pourquoi j'ai entendu ce
jour-là mais c'était peut-être le bon
moment mais je pense que j'avais aussi
besoin de que quelqu'un me déverse tout
son amour et me disent Baptiste en fait
tu as le droit de vivre aussi et ça a
été une boîte sauvetage cette phrase
j'ai j'ai accepté de l'aide et j'ai
accepté véritablement le mot dépendance
alcoolique et je suis allé aux
alcooliques anonymes on pourra peut-être
en reparler mais c'est vrai que ce lien
de pouvoir m'identifier à d'autres moi
qui me sentais tellement seul tellement
différent le mouton noir de mon cercle
social et bien
je voyais des semblables et ça faisait
tellement du bien de sentir que j'avais
ma place quelque part c'était une forme
de réconfort et et peut-être pas de
honte puisque vous étiez entre personnes
c'est ça qui vit traversait aussi ou qui
avait traversé les mêmes problèmes les
mêmes j'avais besoin de sentir de
l'espoir mais surtout d'être compris des
trucs
alors j'ai été tétanisé avant d'y aller
c'est il faut j'imagine c'est pas très
facile d'y aller ça se fait pas facile
du tout mais il y a une chaleur humaine
qui est assez exceptionnelle il y a
aussi beaucoup d'autodérision il y a il
y a de la vie et j'avais peut-être
besoin de vie et dans une forme de
fraternité finalement c'est ça
vous vous écrivez parler c'est le début
du soin à apporter à soi-même
c'est une belle phrase que j'arrive
maintenant à m'approprier j'en ai fait
aussi ma vie aujourd'hui c'est de dire
que la chose la plus courageuse au monde
c'est de sortir du silence et je n'avais
pas accès à des cadres d'expression je
n'ai pas grandi avec des des avec cette
facilité d'exprimer ses émotions j'ai
grandi en cachant beaucoup de choses en
noyant beaucoup de choses en me taisant
et j'ai essayé d'avancer comme un bon
petit soldat en ne pas en never balisant
pas vos émotions en écoutant pas mes
émotions alors que je suis un
hypersensible et que les émotions elles
étaient hyper intenses mais pour moi
c'était pas une notion de virilité je
voulais être viril l'alcool m'a permis
aussi de me sentir viril mais en fait ça
a été encore une fois juste un mensonge
et
la parole vraiment ma liberté
fondamentale ne serait-ce que de pouvoir
ancrer des mots de pouvoir accepter
certaines choses de plus près de ses
émotions en fait
exactement et aussi de se confronter à
la réalité d'arrêter de fuir parce que
l'alcool est une fuite alors vous l'avez
légèrement abordé donc tout à l'heure
vous êtes devenu ce qu'on appelle un
patient expert depuis que vous êtes
sobre c'est bien ça presque ça alors
expliquez-nous qu'est-ce que c'est être
un pack patient expert alors juste pour
la pour le petit contexte au bout d'un
an d'abstinence j'ai eu ce désir de
transmettre des choses de transmettre
mon expérience et dire notamment aux
jeunes que tout ce que j'aurais aimé
qu'on me dise parce que moi j'ai manqué
cruellement de modèles j'ai manqué
cruellement de sensibilisation j'ai eu
voilà un désir de transmission au début
j'avais très très peur de prendre la
parole j'avais pas les mots alors j'ai
utilisé l'écriture
en mode d'expression peut-être qu'on
pourra revenir un peu sur sur ce livre
d'avoir trop trinqué ma vie s'est
arrêtée ça a été une ça fait partie du
processus pour vous
de guérison
et c'est grâce à Judith qui m'a
confronté à tous mes mots qui m'aiguillé
dans mon introspection et qui m'a permis
d'accepter mon passé grâce à ce livre
qui est en autoédition et donc seulement
disponible à l'achat sur mon site
internet je
j'accepte je n'ai plus peur de mon passé
je n'ai plus peur d'en parler et c'est
pendant l'écriture de ce livre que j'ai
découvert le patient expert alors dites
nous c'est quoi passion expert alors un
patient expert c'est un ancien malade
qui reçoit une formation alors moi je
l'ai reçu par la PHP les hôpitaux de
Paris c'est très sérieux c'est très
sérieux bah en fait c'est aussi pour
dire que tout le monde ne peut pas
s'autoproclamer coach un ancien
alcoolique on peut aider des gens qui
qui sont alcooliques j'ai compris ça
dans le dans cette formation là alors
cette formation m'apprend à structurer
mon savoir expérience celle de la
maladie de structurer beaucoup de choses
et de pouvoir accompagner d'autres
personnes qui souffrent de la même
maladie et
quand j'ai brandi ce diplôme entre les
mains ça a été une révélation je suis
tellement fier de ce diplôme parce qu'il
représente qui je suis je ne mens plus
je n'ai plus besoin de mettre de masque
en société et je deviens acteur de ma
maladie c'est assez phénoménal et puis
je suis là pour pour essayer d'aiguiller
éclairer d'être un soutien d'être à
l'écoute comme je l'ai dit ça se soigne
par le lien donc j'essaye d'être un lien
avec ceux dont l'âme est encore dans
l'obscurité donc votre vie aujourd'hui
elle est consacrée à ça à travers des
conférences c'est ça vous sensibilisez
dans des conférences qui se déroulent
dans des collèges dans des lycées
notamment mais pas que peut-être il y a
aussi des en université en école de
commerce école d'ingénieurs pas encore
en médecine j'aimerais bien
mais je suis aussi présent sur les
réseaux sociaux notamment instagram sur
votre Instagram on peut vous
de suivre à travers des réflexions les
conférences auxquelles vous participez
également et je partage un lien en fait
avec un lien et c'est aussi permettre de
d'ouvrir le dialogue d'éveiller les
consciences parce que faut savoir je
suis pas anti-alcool mais je considère
que ce sujet devrait être assez
universel et alors qu'on fait beaucoup
l'autruche on fait encore l'autruche on
n'est pas encore en conscience pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce qu'on boit quelle est la
place qu'occupe l'alcool dans la vie
est-ce qu'il y a des impacts négatifs à
cause de l'alcool ces questions elles
sont accessibles au plus enfin elles
sont accessibles pour tout le monde
c'est pas que pour les personnes qui
sont dans les extrêmes alors j'essaye
d'aborder le sujet sur les réseaux
sociaux et notamment auprès des jeunes
en conférence pour pour les sensibiliser
sur les risques parce que je sais
combien
j'aurais aimé avoir accès à cette
information alors justement et
malheureusement l'émission touche à sa
fin en quelques mots quand on a un
proche qui vit le problème d'addiction
d'alcool quels sont les premiers mots
qu'elle serait les premiers mots ou
quels les mots à les bons mots à dire
pour aider alors j'aurais bien aimé
qu'on me dise qu'on s'inquiète pour moi
je m'inquiète pour toi et une présence
pas du jugement je suis à côté de toi ça
va aller tiens prends une bouteille
d'eau si tu as besoin je suis là mais
d'être dans la posture de la
moralisatrice ou alors quand je suis
bourré d'essayer de me parler quand je
suis bourré ça marche pas ça ne peut pas
fonctionner ça sort ça rentre dans
l'oreille ça sort de l'autre donc
essayez d'avoir des des cadres des
contextes or alcool et de d'essayer de
dire je je suis là en fait je suis
présent je suis là et que l'entourage
aussi puisse accepter que cette
personne-là est malade c'est pas un
manque de volonté moi j'ai longtemps cru
que c'était un manque de volonté c'est
une maladie c'est une maladie et donc
d'essayer d'échanger avec cette personne
malade comme on échangera avec une
personne qui a un cancer ou d'aborder le
sujet de cette façon là merci Baptiste
Mulliez je rappelle votre livre d'avoir
trop trinqué ma vie s'est arrêtée
co-écrit avec Judith losman en CO aux
éditions Judith losman édition et on
retrouve toutes les informations sur
votre compte Instagram merci à vous
d'être venu point de vue c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis on se retrouve demain même heure
même endroit je vous laisse en compagnie
des autres programmes du Figaro à
bientôt
[Musique]